Flash! Michel Marnay,
the French heart crusher,
sailed incog tonight from Naples
onboard the Napoli. Why?
Because Lois Clarke
and her 20 million smackers
will be at the dock palpitating
for him.
And it's good news for us mere men,
because when he arrives,
Michel Marnay goes
out of circulation.
This time, it's marriage.
Voici la nouvelle sensationnelle
qui va briser bien des coeurs.
Michel Marnay, le celebre sportsman,
s'embarque ce soir. Oui!
Well, here we are,
ladies and gentlemen,
and a nice, crisp little titbit has
just come in.
Oh, by the way, I might mention,
I'm speaking from dear old London
as usual.
Well, it's rumoured that Michel
Marnay sails for America tonight
to enter into matrimony, at last,
with one of America's industrial
nobility,
a Miss...a Miss, uh, Lois Clarke.
The rock and gravel heiress.
Stone and sand, you know.
Hmm. Well, that seems to be all.
Goodnight.
Senor Marnay? No.
Senor Marnay!
Senor Marnay? No. Is he onboard?
Yes. Senor Marnay!
Senor Marnay!
Senor Marnay! Senor Marnay?
Mr Marnay, would you autograph
this picture of you? Please?
Write something
we can always remember.
Something sizzling!
Thank you. It's in French! Isn't it
wonderful? I wonder what it means.
"You are very lovely girls,
but you have very bad manners."
WIND WHISTLES
Je me pardonne, madame. Je crois
que vous lisez mon telegramme.
I beg your pardon? I said I believe
you are reading my radiogram.
Oh.
Just a moment.
Well...how do I know it's yours?
Can you identify yourself?
Well... I am Michel Marnay.
Oh, don't tell me you're the fella?!
Yeah.
Well, this is...
This is pretty personal.
Can you tell me what it says?
Well, it says, "Remembering
a warm, beautiful night,
"a thunderstorm over Lake Como,
and you."
And "you" - it's you?
It was all right, huh?
Mm-hm. It was nice?
Thank you.
Do you think it'll ever take
the place of baseball?
What's the matter -
did you lose it again?
Look...
I'm in trouble. Serious trouble.
I could've told you, playing
around Lake Como. The poor thing.
No. I must talk to someone.
Well, I'm really not very good about
that sort of thing. I talk a lot.
I've tried to break myself of the
habit. You have an honest face.
Oh, you... I can trust you, can't I?
Yes, I guess so. Come with me.
But, look, the Captain has an honest
face, too. And the purser,
I thought he had a very honest...
Shall we go to your cabin or mine?
Er...mine.
Well, maybe mine is closer.
Mine is here.
Oh.
Not that I'm prudish, it's just that
my mother told me
never to enter a man's room in any
months ending in R.
Your mother must be a very beautiful
woman.
What's your name? Terry McKay.
Terry McKay.
And I'm travelling alone.
That wasn't by any chance what was
troubling you, was it? Yes.
Oh. Oh, this is fine.
I thought you'd like it.
You saved my life, you know.
I was bored to tears! I haven't seen
one attractive girl on this boat
since we left. Can you imagine?
Nine days like that?
No, this is terrible.
That's not for me!
I should be bright, I should be
beautiful and bubbling
like pink champagne. I got scared.
I said to myself, "Don't beautiful
women travel any more?"
Evidently not. Then I saw you and it
was all right. I was saved. I hope.
Cigarette? No, thank you.
Have you been getting results
with a line like that?
Or would I be surprised? If YOU were
surprised that would surprise me.
That sounds like a nasty crack.
I could make a few, too,
if I felt like it.
I'm sure you could. I know I can.
That's what I said. I think I will.
How's your fiancee?
She's got a cold.
Oh, that's too bad.
Got it at Lake Como?
No. No, she wasn't there.
Oh. Oh, you mean the Lady of the Lake
was not...
That was her best friend.
Oh.
A chummy bunch.
HE CHUCKLES
Yeah.
Oh, this boat is going awfully fast.
Only eight and a half days
till we get in.
Is there any reason why, from now
on, it shouldn't be pink champagne?
Hmm.
Don't tell me he's the fellow?
SHE LAUGHS
Uh-huh.
He's all right, eh? Uh-huh.
He's nice? Uh-huh.
Where is he now?
Well, he's visiting his parents.
He sends me on a buying trip
every once in a...
You see, he's my boss too.
Oh.
You don't think he would approve of
pink champagne? Oh, no, I don't...
Well, I think it's very touching,
you and him.
Very beautiful. I like that.
Oh, good.
He must be a very fascinating
fellow.
Well, you can just imagine
how attractive he is,
when I can resist
so charming a person as you.
Yes. I think I'll go now.
After all, I still have deck tennis
and...keno,
and there is always shuffleboard.
Don't tell me you're embarrassed?
Oh, yes. Yes, I am.
So if you don't mind, I think
I'll take my pride for a walk.
Unless, by chance, you'd care to
have dinner. Oh, I'd love that.
Oh, that would be very nice.
Instead of Mother Goose, you were
probably brought up
on the memoirs of Casanova.
Not at all. Hmm.
But you've heard of the little fella,
haven't you?
I imagine you've known
quite a few women, haven't you?
Or maybe "few" is the wrong word.
And I gather you haven't very much
respect for them?
But you've always been very fair
in your judgments.
I beg your pardon, senor,
would you like me
to reserve this table
for you every night?
Why not?
You know, I... Now, look,
look, let's talk about you now.
Oh, no, not tonight. Let's talk
about me some other night.
All right.
Senor Marnay.
Another one.
And YOUR name, please? McKay.
Ah! Hmm.
Where were we? Hmm.
Oh, yes. What's the name
of that strange place you came from?
Kansas.
And from there?
Well, then I went to New York
and got a job singing in a nightclub
from ten to three in the morning,
and then the manager used to chase me
around his office until about four,
and then I went home. And then
one night, HE came along. Oh, yes.
Yeah. He said I didn't belong
in a place like that.
He said that, um...
Hmm?
I didn't say anything. Oh.
Well, he said that...
That you could improve yourself?
Yeah. So I studied hard.
So that someday you would be
a charming and lovely wife.
Yeah, that was the idea, more or...
Is there anything wrong with that?
Oh, no, no. Well, that's what
I thought. But nothing happened.
Well, that just about brings us
up-to-date.
Now my life's an open book.
It's only one page.
It's the only page.
I beg your pardon.
SHUTTER CLICKS
Thank you very much.
Oh, that's bad. Hmm? Oh.
That's a beautiful camera
you've got there. Oh, yes.
It takes very clear pictures.
Oh, please, monsieur!
Oh.
I guess it isn't any good for
either one of us to be seen together.
Right or wrong, you know,
people like to talk.
It better be goodbye. What's
the matter? Afraid? Of you? No.
Well, after all,
we're on the same ship.
Still have eight days, you know?
Well, you can take nice, long walks
out in the sunshine.
What should I do if it rains?
Nah, it's no good. I see.
It's particularly no good for you.
Yes, that's right.
Being seen with you is news
and I don't want to get my picture
in the paper, so...
I think we better spread out.
Hey! Hey, get me down from here,
will ya?
I got up there
and I couldn't get back.
HE LAUGHS
Can you do that? Sure.
Good. You're quite a fellow. Hey!
You must be quite a guy yourself.
Yes? Why? Well, everybody
on the ship's talking about ya. No.
What do they say about me?
Well, I don't know.
Every time they start talking about
you, they make me leave the room.
BOTH LAUGH
Is that so?
Ohh! Be careful there, sonny.
You'll fall and hurt yourself!
When I was little like you, I fell
and broke my leg! How is it now?
Well, it's all right.
So what are you crabbing about?
Well, I'm not crabbing, I...
just thought that you...
I'm sorry.
Give me a champagne cocktail, will
you? Yes, sir. Got cigarettes?
At the cigarette dispenser.
Pink champagne? Yes.
Champagne cocktail, please.
Yes, madam.
Have you any pink champagne? Yes.
CORK POPS
I changed my table
to a table for one. So did I.
Yeah, it's too bad
it had to be like that.
We had such a delightful dinner
last night.
Parlez-vous inkpay appulay?
What did you say?
Oh...
There's no-one that's fooling the
world... Everybody's watching us.
This is awful!
I think this is awful
and I'm going to go.
Don't you go too!
THEY ARGUE INDISTINCTLY
Hello! Going my way?
Calling on a lady. Even in Madeira?
No, you're wrong this time.
My grandmother. Oh, I'm sorry.
That's all right.
She lives up on the hill.
Would you like to meet her? Yes, I'd
be very happy to. Come on, get in.
Oh, what a divine place!
Oh, I want to meet her. Yes? Just
a minute, I'll see if she's there.
Hello? Hello?
She's not there.
Oh...look.
She must be in the chapel.
Hello, Jackie.
You still remember me?
What is it about this place?
Something makes you feel
you ought to whisper.
Such peace!
It's like another world.
My grandmother's world.
Tell me a little more about her.
My grandfather was in the
diplomatic service,
they lived all over the world.
This was his last post.
He died here.
So she stayed on to be near him.
He's buried there
in the other chapel.
She must be waiting,
I think a little impatiently,
for the day she will join him.
Michel! Mon... Mon cheri!
THEY CONVERSE IN FRENCH
Oh, no. No, no.
May I present Miss Terry McKay.
She thought you were the girl
I'm going to marry.
How do you do? How do you do?
Elle est charmante.
Elle me plait beaucoup.
Pardon. I was only saying I liked
you very much.
Oh, thank you. I'm glad.
If you'll excuse me, I'll sit down
for a moment. Oh, pardon.
I'm longer with my prayers
these days.
And my knees,
well, they are as old as I am.
Are you English?
No, I'm an American. American!
Do you know, my dear, I have
a special fondness for America.
It was my husband's first post
after we married. Really?
In fact, we went to Washington
on our honeymoon.
HE LAUGHS
You have a lovely place here.
Thank you.
I'd like to stay on for ever.
You are too young for that.
It's a good place
to sit and remember,
but you still have to create
your memories.
Would you like to go inside
the chapel? May I?
How long has it been for you,
Michel?
Oh, let's see...
Since you were an altar boy.
Yes. Then you better go in, too.
It won't hurt you. I know.
I'll prepare tea. Good.
I've never seen such lovely colours.
Uh-huh.
Everything's so vivid. Yes.
Even the green seems greener.
Yes, they...they get a lot of
rainfall here.
Who takes care of this place? Hmm?
Oh, an old gardener. There he is!
Michel! On est content de vous voir.
Toi aussi, mon vieux.
Petite nouvelle? Oui. Combien as-tu
eu depuis que je ne t'ai pas vu?
Trois. Oh. He's got three children
since I have seen him. Well!
Emile says, "France needs men!"
So he has seven daughters.
Seven?!
THEY LAUGH
Well, if you'll excuse me, I think
I'll go see the rest of the family.
Dans la maison, monsieur.
Dans la maison?
Tea will be ready any moment. May I
help you? Thank you, my dear.
Oh. Where are your cups? In there.
I have it. Oh, thank you.
I'm sorry, I had to let my maid go.
I have to watch my expenses.
You see, I planned on dying
when I was 75, and here I am 77.
So, if I am not going to die,
I have to start saving my money.
SHE LAUGHS
You like it? Yes, it's charming.
Who did that?
Michel. Michel?!
He painted it for me.
Why, it's good!
He is very talented. Oh, forgive me.
You see, I wouldn't have
any way of knowing.
Unfortunately,
he is also very critical.
As a result, he hasn't done anything
since. What a pity.
Besides, Michel is too busy...
Living? Yes. Thank you.
Things come too easy to him
and he's always allured by the art
he is not practising,
the places he hasn't been,
the girl he hasn't met.
I don't mind confessing to you,
my dear,
that I've been worried about him.
Why? That one day life will
present a bill to Michel
and that he will find it
hard to pay.
But when I see him with you,
I feel better.
Well, I don't understand.
He's going to be married
and settle down.
Can't you just see him
with his slippers and his pipe? No.
There is many a slip betwixt the lip
and the water
and anything could happen on a boat.
Believe me, my dear, there is
nothing wrong with Michel
that a good woman
could not make right.
Well, I saw Emile's entire family.
Seven daughters.
I congratulated him and I had
a nice talk with his wife.
How have you two girls been getting
along? You'd be surprised.
I bet she did all the talking.
Uh-huh.
She told me
that when you were a little boy,
if you didn't get your own way,
you used to lie on the floor and kick
and get red in the face.
And what did YOU say? Well, I said
you didn't do that any more.
Now if you don't get your own way,
you just get embarrassed.
SHE LAUGHS
Hmm.
THEY LAUGH
What have you two been discussing?
Seems a lot has been going on
that I know nothing about!
Well, I'm afraid we must be going.
Michel!
SHIP'S HORN BLASTS
See? Janou, you must play the piano
for us before we go.
Oh, no. She was a great pianist,
you know? Oh, come on.
She's going to play here right now.
Ah! But, Michel, look at my hands.
THEY LAUGH
Right.
That's right.
Remember, I was asked to do this.
TERRY HUMS ALONG TO "Abide With Me"
# J'ai tout quitte pour l'ingrate
Sylvie
# Elle me quitte
et prend un autre amant
# Plaisir d'amour ne dure qu'un
moment
# Chagrin d'amour dure
toute la vie. #
SHIP'S HORN BLASTS
I don't like boat whistles.
I know.
Here. Better have this round you.
Thank you. Isn't it beautiful.
You like it?
I do. I'll send it to you...someday.
This is as far as I can go.
This is the boundary
of my small world.
It's a perfect world.
Thank you for letting me trespass.
Bye. God bless you.
SHIP'S HORN BLASTS
Well, Janou, I'll come back to see
you very soon. Really, I will.
And I shall write very often,
you'll see.
Please do!
SHE SOBS
Goodbye.
Bye.
Bye, Janou.
Oooh!
HE LAUGHS
Looks like stormy weather ahead.
We've changed our course today.
I want to thank you
for a lovely evening.
for what was undoubtedly the
loveliest day I've ever known.
You've been very sweet
to my little grandmother.
I'm going to write to her.
That would be nice.
Well...goodnight.
Goodnight.
We're heading into a rough sea,
Michel.
Goodnight.
If you say, "A penny for your
thoughts," I'll jump overboard!
I thought you'd gone to bed. What
good would that do? I can't sleep.
Yes, I know.
All I seem to do is turn and toss.
Dreaming? I wouldn't call that
dreaming, I'm awake.
I'd call it wishing.
My father used to say,
"Wishes are the dreams we dream
when we're awake."
Your father said that?
He drank a lot.
I wrote a song once...about wishing.
Was nice.
Oh, it was? No, I didn't mean that.
I mean, it was...
You mean it was not bad.
You know, one day I'm going to learn
your language and be very funny too.
SHE LAUGHS
I'm sorry. How does it go?
Hmm?
Oh, I forget.
But it meant...if you wish very hard
with your mind,
and if you wish very strong
in your heart,
and if you keep on wishing
long enough and strong enough...
You get what you want for Christmas?
Yes.
Well...we get in in the morning.
Uh-huh.
Will he be...waiting?
Hmm. And she? Mm-hm.
Mm-hm.
I suppose if we have something
in our minds, we better say it now.
Yes.
You know, I've never worked
in all my life.
In all my life, I've never worked.
I've been thinking about that.
What did you say? Hmm? I didn't
say anything. You did, too.
You said I was very fond of expensive
things. Furs and jewels and things.
Did I say that?
SHE LAUGHS
I guess you and I have been
more or less
used to a life of pink champagne.
Maybe it'd be
a little difficult to... Hmm?
You like beer? Yes, I do, but...
I know, it's bad for the figure.
SHE LAUGHS
My father used to say, "It's a funny
thing, but the things we like best
"are either illegal, immoral
or fattening."
THEY LAUGH
I told you he drank like a fish.
SHE LAUGHS WEAKLY
I wonder what your father would
think of me?
Never working. Not once!
Well, just because you haven't...
Oh, I didn't mean that I couldn't,
of course not.
But, I couldn't find out
all at once.
It would take me, oh, at least six
months to find out if... If what?
Well, it's hard to say.
I'm sorry, it's unfair to ask you
to take a chance.
But...if I work hard enough,
and long enough,
and if wishes came true,
where would you be?
What are you trying to say, Michel?
I'm trying to say that it would
take me six months to find out
if I'm worthy to say
what's in my heart.
Oh, that's just about
the nicest thing.
I think I'll turn in.
Do a little more rolling and tossing.
I'll think it over
and let you know in the morning.
Going my way? No, I think I'll...
I'll walk a little.
Marriage is a very serious step
for a girl like me. Yes, I know.
Do you like children? Oh, yes, I do!
I was so worried, I was wondering...
I'm sorry, I didn't even know
we were in! I'm only half dressed.
If...if everything turns out
all right, for both of us, I mean,
in six months... Yes?
That's July. July, yes.
I've written out these directions.
Read them carefully
so there won't be any mistake.
"Darling..." That's me? Uh-huh.
"July 1st, five o'clock,
"102nd floor,
top of the Empire State Building."
Yes. That's it right there.
It's the tallest building in the
world, you can't miss that. No.
It's the nearest thing to heaven
that we have in New York.
Be sure you take the elevator.
HE CHUCKLES
Well...until we...meet again.
Take care of yourself.
SHIP'S HORN BLASTS
Michael! So glad to see you.
Oh, I'm so glad to see you.
Did you have a nice crossing?
Yes, I had a very nice crossing.
Miss Clarke, would you pose
for a still, please?
Yes. Thank you. One more, please.
Oh...yes. That's it. That's fine.
Now, just one more, Miss Clarke,
please?
One more.
Will this do? Oh, that's fine,
that's fine, Miss Clarke.
Thank you. I'm in a hurry. If you'll
excuse me, I have an appointment.
Just one more.
Michael, I'm so glad you're back.
One more! No, no more!
HUBBUB
Just say something.
Let me look at you. Oh, it's
wonderful to have you back.
Was it a rough crossing?
Well, you wouldn't exactly call it
smooth, we...
I beg your pardon. Oh, excuse us.
Terry, darling,
it's great to have you back.
It's great to be back, Ken.
Your trunk's arrived.
Where's the keys?
Don't unpack, Annie.
I'm moving.
Well, lots of good luck. Thanks.
I hope you'll be working here.
The terms are satisfactory,
but as I said before...
I know, it's not up to you, it's
up to the customer. That's right.
You sing, then we'll talk.
And if I can't find you,
I'll understand. That's right!
# Go on and sing, my heart
# You know it's spring, my heart
# So why not show it?
# Pretend you're glad, my heart
# Although you're sad, my heart
# He mustn't know it
# Remember love is not an easy game
# No two hearts ever beat
quite the same
# Go on and dance, my heart
# This is romance, my heart
# So keep pretending
# Do not despair, my heart
# We still may share, my heart
# That happy ending
# If it's to be we soon shall see
# And if it's not to be
# No power on Earth can make it so
# You know it's spring, my heart
# Go on and sing, my heart
# For if you sing
# He'll never know. #
APPLAUSE
How am I doing, chief?
That noise is applause, isn't it?
Oh, well, maybe they're applauding
your two-dollar dinner?
I'd like to talk a long contract.
Six months? That's not a long time.
Oh, yes, it is.
APPLAUSE
# Go on and dance, my heart
# This is romance, my heart
# So keep pretending
# Do not despair, my heart
# You still may share, my heart
# That happy ending
# If it's to be we soon shall see
# And if it's not to be
# No power on Earth can make it so
# You know it's spring, my heart
# Go on and sing...
# And he will know! #
APPLAUSE
Oh, I've brought you something!
You're always so nice to me. Nice!
But you are my nicest boarder.
Well, no matter what you say,
I'm not going to pay you a cent more.
Oh! Who wants more money?
I am so happy you are here.
You're always happy.
What's the secret?
Oh, I don't know. I don't know.
My place is half empty,
I have rheumatism,
and my husband left me
with five children
and they are all ashamed of me!
SHE LAUGHS
Oh, I'm sorry. Oh, you shouldn't be
sorry, you should be happy.
There is no boyfriends calling on
you, so you don't get married.
And if you don't get married, your
children won't be ashamed of you!
SHE LAUGHS
Well, goodnight. And don't you read
late, it's bad for your eyes.
Goodnight. I'm not going to worry
about anything.
Oh, you know,
I joke a lot about marriage,
but it can be a beautiful thing.
You know, you should get married if
you find the right man, of course.
I don't know where you will find
him, of course,
but don't you marry a loafer
like I did.
It's just as easy to marry a man
with lots of money.
Maybe you don't love him at first,
but you can teach yourself in six
easy lessons.
Just don't you marry a loafer. I
married one, he was a prize winner.
Yep...
I was hoping you would like
one of...
Well, I suppose if I can't sell
my paintings, I'll get a job.
Oh, I wouldn't give up painting.
Why, painting...
I'm not going to give it up.
This is the only thing I know.
But I've got to make money. A lot
of money. Of course, of course.
In order to make money,
you must eat.
Even the new money gets hungry,
you know?
CAR HORN
Michel. Michel!
Oh.
I have good news for you! What?
I've sold one. Which one?
The woman.
I got a hundred dollars for her!
HE LAUGHS
BOTH LAUGH
What are you so happy about?
I'm a painter! So am I.
But I ain't happy!
HE LAUGHS
Miss McKay, my dear.
My favourite customer.
Welcome home. Thank you.
How well you're looking.
Yes, I know. I didn't get it here.
Where have you been
all these months?
Out of town. Oh, my dear,
we've missed you.
Well, I've missed you, too, Miss...
Lane.
Miss Lane, I want to get something
so beautiful...
um, simple, you understand,
but breathtaking.
Oh, of course! Miss Web,
look who's back. Oh, Miss McKay!
We were just saying, "Whatever
happened to Miss McKay?"
And here you are.
Isn't it wonderful!
Miss McKay is here
and we were just wondering...
Miss McKay is there? Well, give her
anything in the shop,
but hold her till I get there,
will ya?
You weren't worried about her credit,
were you? Yes.
Yes, that's what we were wondering.
I knew you'd understand, Mr Bradley.
Thank you so much.
Hmm. I don't think you could make
a mistake on either one.
Oh...excuse me, please.
Where shall we have this sent?
Well, I don't know at the moment.
I'll have to call back
and let you know.
I think that's right, isn't it?
No...no charge?
No, no. No? I know, I know.
No. No, no.
Oh. Goodbye, Miss McKay.
Goodbye, Miss McKay.
Do come back again soon. Yes,
don't stay away so long, my dear.
Thank you. Goodbye.
Goodbye, Miss McKay.
Terry. Ken! What are you doing here?
How on Earth did YOU know I was here?
Oh. Oh, I see. What time is it, Ken?
I'm late. Five minutes to five.
It's good to see you, Ken.
It's wonderful to see you again.
I've got so much to talk about.
Can't we go...?
Oh, no, I'm in a hurry.
But I've got so much to say.
Well, call me up sometime.
No, you can't do that, either,
when I'm going to be married.
Oh, then, you are going to...
Yes, Ken and I'm late.
What time did you say it was?
Four minutes to five. It looks like
I came all the way down here
just to tell you what time it was.
Yes. Goodbye, Ken. Goodbye.
Good luck! Thanks, Ken.
You can imagine how excited I am,
I thought 34th Street was that way
and it's down here!
I'll get out here, I'm in a hurry.
Here you are. What's the rush?
I'm going to be married
and I'd like you to be the first
to congratulate me.
Thank you so much.
TYRES SCREECH
SCREAMING
Going down? No.
SIREN APPROACHES
SIREN DEPARTS
Going down? No.
What time have you got?
Ten after five.
THUNDER
Going down?
Yeah.
THUNDER CRACKS
Doctor...
What do you think?
Her X-rays aren't very encouraging.
It's hard to say
if she'll ever walk again.
We can tell better
in about six months.
Are you the fellow she was
yelling about under the anaesthetic?
Er...no, no. That's another chap.
She was on her way to marry him.
Has he been notified? No. She...she
doesn't want that, because...
until she knows what you say
you won't know for six months,
she'd rather he didn't know.
That's being sensible. Nice girl.
I think so. Excuse me.
Well, we weren't sure whether or not
we'd have you with us today.
Father, this is the man...
He and I... Yes, he explained.
Then you know...
I was on my way to be married.
But while I was on my way
to be...a good girl...
..I got hit right in the intersection
of 34th and 5th.
Wasn't anybody's fault but my own.
I had an appointment...way up.
I didn't want to keep him waiting.
Oh, it could've been beautiful.
Marriage, I mean. Children.
Forgive me, Father.
I'm a little weak.
I don't get a lot of exercise.
Janou?
DISTANTLY,
TERRY SINGS ALONG WITH PIANO
Monsieur Michel,
she gave me this to send to you.
I was going to mail it today.
She said it was for the young lady
that was here with you.
TERRY'S SINGING CONTINUES
Hello, Miss McKay. Oh, hello.
How are you feeling? I'm all right.
How are you? Fine. Fine.
How are you, Patsy Jane? Fine.
She's got on
a red flannel petticoat. Don't!
Aw! Well, it's warmer!
I'll bet it is.
Been practising your song? Uh-huh.
Know your parts today? Sure.
I knew mine yesterday. Is that so?!
Oh, come on, come on. Let's try it.
I've been practising, too.
Wait till you hear me.
One, two...
ALL: # Wishing will make it so
# Just keep on wishing
and care will go
# Dreamers tell us dreams come true
# It's no mistake
# And wishes are the dreams we dream
when we're awake
# The curtain of night will part
# If you are certain
within your heart
# So if you wish long enough
# Wish strong enough
# You will come to know
# Wishing will make it so. #
CHILDREN CHEER AND APPLAUD
Sing it again! Sing it again!
Sure we'll sing it again.
One, two...
# Wishing will make it so
# Just keep on wishing
# And care will go
# Dreamers tell us... # Get her!
GIRL SCREAMS
I hope you're not angry. Oh, no, no.
But when you have as many youngsters
on your hands as I have,
you have a problem.
Oh, I don't know. I like them.
I do, too. But they don't like me.
They call me Picklepuss.
At heart,
they're just little savages.
But music, you know, has charms
to soothe the savage breast.
And if it has such an influence,
and if you can do so much
in a few days, I'm thinking...
I wonder if you're thinking
the same thing I am?
Music has charms and I like children
and children like me.
And... I'll be getting out of here
pretty soon.
When I do,
I'll be needing a job badly.
It will be only an experiment,
you understand? Yes, I know.
We can't pay a high...
Oh, I know. I know.
Just say you'll pay me enough
that I don't go around calling you
Picklepuss.
Yes.
I'd like to give them a surprise.
So if you don't say anything,
I won't say anything.
I won't say a word.
ALL: We won't tell anybody either!
I must say, you've become
a better painter, my friend.
Maybe you'll become a better critic.
BOTH LAUGH
Six months of hard work.
Well, I'm glad you haven't wasted
your time, my friend.
I've sold everything but this.
I told them to take it out of the
window since you telephoned me.
Oh, thanks.
This is the best, I think.
Yes, I'm not exactly ashamed of it,
myself.
You don't want to sell it, eh?
No, I don't want to sell it.
I wouldn't mind getting rid of it,
but somehow I don't want to...
take money for it. Oh.
I thought maybe you were keeping it
because...you were...
you were nursing a broken heart, eh?
HE LAUGHS
No. No, a broken heart
is not for me.
Life is what you make it.
From now on, I'm taking my fun
where I find it.
Oh, well, I'll be seeing you soon
again. Bye.
Merry Christmas. Merry Christmas
to you, my friend.
Michael! I heard you were in town.
I've had a terrible time
running you down.
Ah, you've been gone a long time,
mon ami.
And I've been thinking about you
morning, noon, night
and in-between times.
What?!
Why, I know you've been busy,
but you could make the theatre
tonight, couldn't you?
Well, I'll leave a ticket
at your hotel.
CHORUS SINGS
APPLAUSE
Where shall we go from here?
Why, Michael, that's up to you -
after all, this is your evening.
I don't know where to go any more.
I just came back, you know?
Hello. Hello.
Let me tell him. No.
I'll go get him. No. No.
It's tough. First time you're able
to get out,
and you have to meet HIM.
All I could say was, "Hello."
Well, the show's over.
The boy got the girl. Shall we go?
It seems terrible taking you home
with everybody going out.
I'm going to ask you once more,
why don't you let me help you?
And I'm going to tell you once more,
if I let you finance
my getting well, he wouldn't like it.
And if he wouldn't like it,
then I wouldn't like it.
And if you did get me well and I went
to him, you wouldn't like it.
Then, certainly, he ought to know.
No, because if he found out,
he'd want to do something about it.
Then if I didn't get well,
he wouldn't like it, and I wouldn't
like it, you wouldn't like it.
It would be awful! No, unless I can
walk to him one day -
and when I say walk, I mean run -
he'll never know.
But I've got my job now
and I'm on a budget
and if everything works out all right
and I'm a good little girl,
maybe I'll get what I want
next Christmas.
Thank you, ladies. Goodnight.
Are you sure you don't want to come
with us?
The evening is so young
and everything.
No, I think I'll turn in.
Some other time.
Merry Christmas, everybody.
Merry Christmas.
Taking you to the theatre wasn't a
very good idea, was it, Michael? No.
HE LAUGHS
Merry Christmas, Lois.
Merry Christmas, Michael. Thank you.
What's the matter, buddy?
Feeling sorry for yourself?
Yeah. Yeah?
You don't know what troubles are.
Look at me, I live at 186th Street
and they won't let me on the subway.
HE LAUGHS
Oh, excuse me, lady.
Good morning. Good morning.
She's not feeling very well.
Oh, that's too bad. But she wants
to see you. Go on in. Thank you.
Merry Christmas.
ALL: Merry Christmas!
Merry Christmas!
Good morning.
ALL: Morning, Miss McKay.
Hello. Hello.
I've bad news for you.
Doctor says I can't go.
ALL: Aw!
Look, Doctor, I could be back
in a couple of hours.
This is a Christmas benefit.
It's their first public appearance!
This is my team!
She's our coach, Doc! Doctor.
HE SNIGGERS
Doctor.
If it was going to hurt her, you
wouldn't want her to go, would you?
ALL: No.
You really don't need the piano.
Come on, go through it once
without me.
The only place you might get stuck
is right at the beginning,
and Aloysius can sing an "A"
in his sleep. Can't ya, Al?
Sure. Come on, let's hear it.
# Ahh! #
See? Now, ready. One, two...
ALL: # Wishing will make it... #
Where's Patsy Jane?
She's got a sore throat
and she won't be able
to go on the stage.
Aw! Come here, darling.
Aw! A pretty new dress, too.
HOARSELY: Hello, Miss McKay.
Aw! You really want to go
on the stage?
Well, then, I tell you what you do,
you go right along with the rest
of them and you pretend to sing.
You know, make believe. Like this.
And they'll never know
the difference.
HOARSELY: Thank you, Miss McKay.
You're welcome.
Now come on, pitch pipe, give!
# Ahh! #
One, two... Now, not too loud -
there's a baby upstairs.
One, two.
ALL: # Wishing will make it so
# Just keep on wishing
# And care will go
# Dreamers tell us dreams come true
# It's no mistake
# That wishes are the dreams we dream
when we're awake
# The curtain of night will part
# If you are certain
within your heart
# So if you wish long enough
# Wish strong enough
# You will come to know
#...Wishing will make it... so! #
Oh, that's swell! That's keen!
You see, you don't need me.
Now, go on.
Go out there and fight
for good old Washington Heights!
ALL: Merry Christmas!
Goodbye!
Goodbye! Good luck!
Merry Christmas! Thank you.
HOARSELY: Merry Christmas.
Merry Christmas, Patty!
Well, this isn't going to be much
of a Christmas for you, is it?
No, I guess not.
Oh, wait. There.
Thank you. Are you comfortable?
Yes, I'm all right.
If you want anything, you just call.
I will.
Michel!
Hello.
How are you, Terry?
It's good to see you!
Yes, it's good to see you, too.
Feeling all right? Oh, yes,
I'm fine. I'm just resting. Oh.
It's been a long time.
Yes. Yes, that's right.
Good to see you.
Yes, you said that.
May I? Oh, yes, sit down. Thank you.
Only a little minute.
You sure you don't mind, I...?
I bet you're wondering
how I got here.
I was looking in the telephone book
for a man named McBride,
when I saw the name of Terry McKay.
So I said to myself, "Could that be
Terry McKay, my old friend?"
SHE LAUGHS
And it was. Yes.
Then I said to myself, "I haven't
been very nice to Miss McKay."
After all, I had an appointment
with her one day at...
And...I didn't keep it.
That wasn't a very nice way
to treat an old friend, was it?
No.
So I said to myself,
"I must apologise." And here I am.
That's sweet of you.
Yes, I think so.
I often wondered about you,
how you were. Oh, you did? Really?
Well, I... often wondered about you,
too.
So...you didn't get angry
because I wasn't there?
What do YOU think?
Well, you must have been at first.
Yes, I...I was. That's what I
thought. At first, I was furious.
I said, "He can't do a thing like
this to me! Who does he think he is?"
And how long did you...
I mean, did you wait long?
Well, let's see.
I...I waited until about...
Midnight? Oh!
And then what did you do?
Well, then I was REALLY mad.
You can just imagine up there.
In a thunderstorm.
Yes.
And then
what did you say to yourself?
Well, then I said, "Why don't you
go home and get tight?"
HE LAUGHS
You didn't do that. Didn't I?
Maybe you took a little one
every hour for about a month.
Well, can you blame me?
I should say not.
The least I could have done
was to send you a note.
Well, maybe when you thought
about it,
you didn't know where to reach me?
But...you swore that if you
ever saw me again, you'd ask.
You didn't? No.
No, I remembered we said
if we could make it, we'd be there,
and if one of us didn't show up
there must have been
a darn good reason.
But what, for instance? And the
other one shouldn't ask questions.
Asking questions is...
Life must be bright. We must keep it
beautiful and bubbling
like pink champagne.
So there'll be no questions asked...
I hope.
Cigarette?
Thank you.
HE LAUGHS
Think of me, walking all
the way up here, ten blocks, to...
HE LAUGHS
And instead, I promise not even
to ask you why you didn't show up.
You knew I was going to? It doesn't
seem fair, somehow. I know.
I don't know what it is,
but when I'm with you, I...
Well...
No wedding ring? No.
Well, I thought
when I saw you at the...
At the theatre last night?
No, he was... No.
I didn't mean to offend you.
How's everything with you, Michel?
Oh, so YOU can ask questions? Yeah.
Well, I thought everything was fine
until I saw you last night.
Then I knew there must be something
between us.
Even if only an ocean.
Oh. So I bought myself a ticket.
Sailing? Yes.
Tonight.
Yep.
Well...
You're happy, aren't you?
Uh-huh.
And you? Well, I don't know.
I'm worried about the future,
what people will think of me.
They'll say, "There he goes,
the mad painter."
There must be something the matter
with him. He doesn't like women.
HE LAUGHS
You mean,
he won't even speak to them?
Oh, yes, yes. He sails the seven
seas, and to every woman he meets
he says,
"Where will you be in six months?"
And they're there? Everywhere!
Eiffel Tower, pyramids, everywhere -
waiting.
But he didn't... Where is he?
Waiting?
Oh, you...you want to change
the subject?
Uh-huh.
SHE LAUGHS
Merry Christmas!
Oh, I almost forgot.
Well...six months ago
who would have thought
we'd spend Christmas together?
By the way, I have a present
for you. A present?
Well, I wish I had something for you.
Well, you didn't know
I was going to...
Anyway, it's not really
a Christmas present. Oh.
So that's why my letters...
came back.
She wanted you to have it. Remember?
Yes, I remember.
I would've sent it to you,
only I didn't know your address
until two days ago.
Well, goodbye, Terry.
Goodbye, Michel.
Well...
You know, I painted you like that...
with a shawl.
I wish you'd seen it. Cobert says -
he's my dealer -
he's says
it's the best thing I've done.
I didn't think I would ever part
with it,
but there was no reason
for keeping it any more.
And then he told me about a girl
who came into his shop.
He told me she liked it very much.
I suppose she saw in it, well...
what I'd hoped YOU'D see.
So I told him to give it to her
because he said she was poor.
And not only that,
he told me that she...
He told...
He said... Yes?
Anyway, I...
I told him to give it to her.
Yes. She couldn't afford it
and it was Christmas season.
And you know me,
big-hearted Michel.
What time does your boat sail? Boat?
Why didn't you tell me, Terry?
Darling!
If anything had to happen to one
of us, why did it have to be you?
Oh, don't look at me like that.
It wasn't anybody's fault but my own.
I was looking...up
at the 102nd floor.
It was the nearest thing to heaven...
You see...
..you were there.
Oh! Ohh!
Don't worry...
it doesn't have to be a miracle.
If you can paint, I can walk.
THEY LAUGH
Anything can happen, don't you think?
Yes, I think so.
THEY LAUGH
Subtitles by Red Bee Media Ltd